Congratulations.
You've made it to the end of the, the content of what we have to teach you.
Now you know about everything from the beginning, the data sets,to evaluation at the end.
>> And I have to say I'm a big fan of you that you made it this far.
It's actually quite a bit of work.
It was work for us too I should say, but it's great to still have you in class.
And I hope you're going to enjoy the final little bit,
which is a little more hands on work.
>> A little more hands on work in the projects, and then a summary.
>> And a summary of the big picture ideas, and then we can let you go hopefully
with a certificate that you can use for wonderful things like getting a job